en prenant le premier tableau qui était
à sa portée ODIL SAU ne se doutait pas
qu'un jouris de professionnel allait
saluer son travail et pourtant sa fille
comme une amie l'avait vivement incité à
participer au Prix sellimen 3è prix pas
moi 2è prix pas moi je dis bon je suis
sortie je je prenais la le chemin de la
sortie et puis j'ai entendu mon nom et
c'était le premier prix j'en revenais
pas une surprise mais avant tout une
reconnaissance de ses pères et de l'île
qui est devenue sa terre d'accueil je me
sens chez moi à la Réunion en tant que
peintre et ça c'était le plus beau
cadeau que cette île pouvait me faire
une œuvre partie d'un croquy dessiné à
la gare routière de Saint-Leu plusieurs
femmes maahoraaises discutent en
attendant le bus pas mal de femmes
attendaient le le bus et notamment des
mauraises qui discutaient entre elles
avec leurs enfants et je trouvais la
scène très belle donc j'avais fait
quelques croquis et j'ai eu envie de
faire un tableau à l'huile de d'un de
ces croquis et de
ressortir
l'esprit la féminité la maternité qui se
dégageait de d'une d'une de ces femmes
le premier prix de ce concours sellimen
c'est aussi un symbole fort
d'intégration au monde artistique toutes
les portes ou presque se sont ouvertes
ça m'a apporté je
pense la confiance en moi qui me
manquait la confiance que les autres ont
mis en moi aussi
et puis ça m'a ouvert des portes ça m'a
permis de m'intégrer un petit peu dans
le monde artistique de la Réunion la
première chose qui est arrivée juste
après le prix sellimen c'est
l'invitation à participer au carrefour
d' contemporain au tampon et puis en
plus après ça s'est pas arrêté après
j'ai eu pas mal de propositions
d'expo et puis ça m'a permis de de
travailler travailler de de faire mûir
un style plus plus
affirmé de créer mon personnage qui est
la petite personne avec laquelle je
travaille maintenant tout le temps et
qui qui me permet de de transmettre
tout ce que je veux dire avec ma
peinture et les projets foissonnent ODIL
part prochainement s'essayer à l'art
dans l'Hexagone un nouveau défi un
nouveau projet de vie dont la Genèse a
été écrite en partie grâce à sa
participation au prix
sellimen